- [Narrator] Located in a waterfront park
known as the Gardens by the
Bay is Supertree Grove.
This mechanical forest
is a utopia for nature
in a very urban location.
(bouncy, lively electronic music)
Supertree Grove was
commissioned by the Singapore
government with the intention of raising
the quality of life for its residents
by enhancing greenery
and flora in the City.
This manmade mechanical forest
consists of 18 Supertrees.
The trees range between
80 to 160 feet high
and are connected by a
walkway, which allows visitors
to cross between them and view the City
from the treetops.
With their thick trunks
and network of thin, neuron-like
branches, each tree
acts as a vertical garden.
Over 160,000 varieties of orchids, ferns,
and other climbing plants
have been planted in the trees.
The trees also generate solar power.
11 of the trees are fitted
with solar photovoltaic systems
that convert sunlight into energy.
This provides lighting
that allows the trees
to come alive at night,
making this an all day,
all season horticultural heaven.
(chiming)